dans les salles du musée mais code 84
robe la moitié sont de balenciaga
l'autre moitié sont des créations de
grands couturiers qui sont inspirés
balenciaga ou vous voulez tout les
acheter l'assureur les évalue à près
d'un million et demi dollar
balenciaga mort en 1972 est surtout
connu du milieu de la mode
il est peut-être moins connus parce que
même dans son époque il fuyait les
médias
c'est quelqu'un qui était assez timide
qui il et espagnols du pays basque et
s'est installé à paris en 1937 où il a
ouvert une maison de couture balenciaga
n'a jamais eu la notoriété des chanel
dior saint-laurent mais a créé des robes
au style unique
il y avait la robe sac de 1958 qui était
un peu juste et en avant mais très très
ample en arrière il ya aussi l'europe
qu'on appelait baby doll ainsi m trapèze
très très large dans un tissu très
fluide
il ya sa robe enveloppe qui était
vraiment une exploration des propriétés
d'un tissu qui s'appelle le gazar que
lui même a fait développer avec un
compagnie textile pour mieux montrer
comment certains couturiers sont
inspirés de balenciaga
une vidéo à l'expo montre la
transformation en continu d'europe de
balenciaga qui deviennent
progressivement les robes d'autres
créateurs
ses robes sont arrivés tout droit de
londres par bateau 91 caisse robes
chapeaux accessoires de grandes
précautions sont prises lors du
décrassage
chaque robe est minutieusement inspectée
par des représentants du musée victoria
and albert pour établir que leur état à
l'arrivée à montréal est le même qu'au
départ à londres
heureusement car cette exposition là ce
qui était vraiment sympathique c'est
clément qui arrive est tout d'un coup
vous l'avez vu tout à l'heure
tout d'un coup donc ça facilite le
travail des techniciens
c'est une exposition clients mais c'est
à dire que le musée mccord l'a achetée à
peu près telles qu'elles du victoria and
albert qui avait déjà monté et présenté
l'expo balenciaga l'hiver dernier à
londres
adaptation montréalaise on a ajouté des
robe balenciaga qui vient de la
collection du musée mais code
à l'époque il était possible d'en
acheter au canada on pouvait aussi comme
la riche canadienne de retenir l'homme
se rendre directement chez le couturier
avait les moyens d'aller à paris
s'habiller chez balenciaga et elle avait
le goût pour des produits très luxueux
et quand on allait chez balenciaga
c'était du sérieux
les clientes étaient soumises à des
séances d'essayage pour que la robe leur
fasse parfaitement balenciaga était
connu pour être minutieux
perfectionniste on l'a vu dans ce défilé
est satisfait du résultat arraché
carrément la mange une de ses robes tous
les créateurs sont influencés par ces
principes c'est principe de minimalisme
de perfection de coop de soucis de
dépassionner pour mieux voir ce
perfectionnisme le musée victoria nos
bêtes est allé jusqu'à soumettre aux
rayons x les robes de balenciaga fait
par exemple apparaître l'armature de
cette robe fabriquée à paris en 54
tiens on voit autre chose d'inusité des
hôtes baleines et à dérape de balenciaga
cole qui ont d autres baleines et qui
sont supposément des espèces en voie
d'extinction
donc ça prend un permis d'exportation
juste pour ses serres bloc parce qu'elle
des morceaux de banane de bas des salons
feutrés des clientes privilégié dans les
années 60 balenciaga a refusé de se
lancer dans le prêt à porter comme l'ont
fait ses concurrents 1968 la france et
le monde change c'est la fin pour
balenciaga
ils ferment boutique aujourd'hui la
marque balenciaga existe toujours
rachetée par le groupe de luxe kering
qui possèdent des grandes marques comme
yves saint laurent et gucci l'exposition
à cette autre qualité de nous replonger
dans l'univers d'origine de balenciaga
[Musique]